In my classroom, I'll grasp onto any technology that can expand the kids' possibilities.
Learning comes from a teacher that's willing to take a risk and do something new...
...and bring in these powerful tools.
One of the key tools we're using right now is Skype to connect with other classrooms.
It's so powerful to connect them beyond these four walls.
Mystery Skype is a chance for the kids to connect with other students around the world.
It's a challenging game for them.
They have to critically think.
Are you in the US?
No, we're not.
Are you somewhere in Mexico?
Yes.
It's a powerful tool to see kids learning from each other.
To see their critical thinking process is far better than any test I could give them.
I mean, really, it takes a team to do anything in life...
...and it's a chance for them to experience that collaboration.
Are you in Baja California?
No.
Are you in Mexico City?
Yes, we are.
Great game!